salut les métallos aujourd'hui on va
mélanger mémoire mathématiques
mentalisme
vous m'avez demandé plusieurs fois si
j'avais une technique une méthode pour
retenir les formules de mathématiques là
dedans
la réponse est oui et je ferme ce volet
pour qu'on arrête de me regarder par la
fenêtre on va encore utiliser ce bon
vieux cerveau pour créer des faux
souvenirs à base d'image mais là
beaucoup plus simple que ce qu'on a pu
voir dans des méthodes généralistes caen
s'est appliqué aux maths je trouve que
la méthode est assez assez cool j'allais
dire sexy mais oui elle est assez sexy
en fait on va créer des images pour ce
genre de formules mathématiques
sauf que on n'a pas besoin d'avoir une
règle définie les images parleront
d'elle-même ensuite et la saynète qui
vous reviendra sera traductible très
facilement vous allez le faire vous même
alors je vous montre le processus pour
arriver à créer les vôtres
c'est assez facile je viens d'écrire une
formule au hasard j'ai écrit quoi x égal
à carrer + 3 av / racine carrée de -9 ok
pour cette formule et pour d'autres
j'utilise un côté universel pour deux
trois choses le signe égal quand c'est
diviser les parenthèses le carré la
racine carrée ça pour moi à chaque fois
c'est le même image c'est le même code
égal ce sont des barres parallèles
beaucoup de mener nos techniciens
utilisent cette image pour le diviser
c'est bien de diviser un lieu en deux
par exemple une maison avec un étage une
salle de spectacle avec un balcon tout
ce qui est en haut et au dessus dû
utiliser et tout ce qui est en bas et en
dessous du diviser pour la racine cas je
vous recommande de choisir toujours la
même image quelque chose qui enferme
quelque chose de gros comme une maison
comme un hangar ou alors un tivoli un
seul géant ce que vous voulez un car et
je laisse aussi un quart est donc à une
boîte heynckes un coffre fort ce genre
de choses et pour tout ce qui est plus
est - j'utilise des charges vous allez
vite comprendre je reprend la formule
d'exemple x égale quelque chose alors le
x il faut que je trouve quelque chose
qui commence par la lettre x et qui me
fasse penser après spontanément à ce x
ce sera chaque fois mon point de départ
pour cette formule
donc pour ce x l'a spontanément je vais
prendre de charles xavier déjà parce que
c'est charles xavier et que c'est le mec
des x-men donc comme ça mon x y sera
bien défini je vais pas l'imaginer dans
son fauteuil néanmoins je vais
l'imaginer en train de faire des barres
parallèles
il est au premier plan dans mon image
charles xavier en train de faire des
barres parallèles et là j'ai mon x égal
il est maintenu comme c'est moi qui
viens de créer l'image je sais que je
pourrai l'art traduire plus tard mais il
fait pas des barres parallèles n'importe
où il fait des barres parallèles sur la
scène de l'olympia et devant lui il y à
tous le lympia et lamont
regards changent et je vois tout
l'olympia donc toute la fosse qu'on
appelle la fosse elba et le balcon sur
les tâches de mon balcon se trouve un
ananas géant ea les géants il est énorme
et il est enfermé dans une boîte
transparente donc j'ai un ananas gens
enfermés dans une boîte de transparents
ca au carré et à côté de cette analyse
sur sa droite parce que dans ma tête je
lis toujours de gauche à droite il y a
trois brebis trois petites brebis et
elles sont en train de sourire à elles
ont un smile mon pote
il est énorme et comme elle sourit ça
veut dire qu'elles sont positives donc
ça veut dire que j'ai plus trois brebis
donc j'ai plus 3 b parce que j'ai pris
le bébé pur brebis et ensuite à l'étagé
inférieur c'est à dire dans la fosse de
l'olympia je vais avoir une grande toile
de tente une immense toile de tente
c'est un peu un tivoli à toi de le temps
que j'ai pas trop ce que j'ai fait dans
ma tête et sous ses toiles de tentes
on peut voir plein duff qui sont
complètement pété plein d'offres qui
sont casser des oeufs cassés des eaux
casser des oeufs cassés donc oeuf pour
moi c'est neuf et si vous utilisez une
tête de rappel je vous propose quand
vous avez comme ça une constante de
prendre l'image de votre top de rappel
et ils sont cassés c'est négatif c'est
une énergie négative donc je sais que
c'est moins 9
hélas si je reprends mon image de
charles xavier sur des barres parallèles
sur la scène de l'olympia en face de lui
au balcon il ya un ananas géant dans une
boîte transparente et à côté il ya trois
produits qui sourit juste en dessous il
ya une espèce de toile de tente géante
avec des oeufs écrasé par tous là je
peux traduire directement que x égal
alors au-dessus a au carré plus 3b est
en dessous donc / racine carrée de -9
pour les parenthèses vous pouvez
utiliser beau symbole moi je prends
souvent les frères bogdanoff quand il y
en a un c'est lui qui a pour avantage
carrière le deuxième c'est la fin de la
parenthèse trouver des choses comme ça
qui marche en binaire pour les
parenthèses c'est cool je m'en suis
servi dans ma scolarité pour toutes les
formules même les fonctions les dérivés
des choses qui ont l'air comme ça vous
compliquez des très grosses formule ça
fonctionne très très bien en plus de ça
un endroit où vous n'avez pas le droit
aux formules je ne vous dis pas tricher
attention si vous marquez sur un petit
bout de papier la première image d'une
formule vous allez voir que toute la
scène va vous revenir assez facilement
si vous avez d'autres méthodes autre
astuce pour mémoriser les formules
mathématiques parlons-en dans les
commentaires c'est toujours bien plus ça
va plus vous vous donnez des conseils
dans les commentaires entre vous et je
trouve ça super en fait pour la culture
la connaissance et les changements à
voler menthe à l'eau si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo alors n'oubliez pas les
images mentales pour ou sommet
et n'oubliez pas également de vous
abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
c'est important on est presque à 100
milles et oui j'avais fait une promesse
pour les cent mille abonnés promesse que
je vais tenir je suis déjà en train de
travailler dessus si vous connaissez pas
cette promesse regarder la première fois
aux questions que j'ai fait sur la
chaîne allez rendez vous demain à 17h le
mental bugs et une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
ciao je joue mon spectacle en entier le
23 septembre à la garenne colombes c'est
la date la plus proche de paris si
jamais vous voulez venir sinon il ya
toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site